SEBASTIAN THRUN: It's a great
pleasure seeing all of you
this afternoon.
If you paid attention
in Sundar's keynote,
among all these
wonderful announcements
was a very small,
petite announcement
pertaining to education.
Sundar announced what we call
a nanodegree online education
for Android development, which
means anybody in the room who
is either an Android developer
or aspires to be an Android
developer or wants
to work for Google
or one of its
partner companies now
has an opportunity to learn
from the best of the best what
it means to be a top
notch Android developer.
We put together a
short video which
I want to show you about it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The reason why I'm
an Android developer
is because of the
platform's massive reach.
Building for Android means that
you can build something here
and it will reach people all
the way across the world.
In fact, the next billion
people coming online
will interact with the internet
for the very first time using
only a mobile device.
There's so many people who
are consumers of technology,
but I think it's so
much more powerful
to be a creator of technology.
Everyone has unique
experiences and strengths
and they can draw
on that and use
that to identify problems
in their community
and then use technology
to solve that.
I really feel like
there's a big opportunity
to show people that
they can create
something really amazing.
You can imagine something
that you think should exist
and you can actually
go and build it.
I can't think of anything
more powerful than that.
You can start your journey
to become an Android
developer today with Udacity
and Google's nanodegree.
[END PLAYBACK]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: The person
who first and foremost
deserves credit is
actually sitting over there
in the first row.
Peter, want to get
up for a second?
[APPLAUSE]
This is Peter Lubbers,
who put together
a wonderful team of Googlers
to really bring education
to everybody, not just knowledge
and information, but education.
And he teamed up with my
startup company called Udacity
to really change education.
So let's go back a
few years and tell you
the story of how we came about.
About four years ago, I
was busy raising Google X,
working on self driving
cars, contact lenses that
could measure your
glucose level,
balloons in the
stratosphere-- in fact,
there's a parallel talk right
now about Project Loon--
and many other things, Google
Glass, when Peter Norvig,
who is speaking in about
half an hour about education,
and I decided to take a
Stanford class online.
I was teaching in my free
time at Stanford, an advanced
artificial intelligence
class, and following
Sal Khan and many
other people I admire,
we decided to make it available
for the world, not just
Stanford students.
So here's our context of this.
At that time, colleges
were under fire.
They had raised tuition
rates by about 7.5%
for 30 consecutive years.
The nation was facing a credit
card debt of more than $1
trillion and the
return of investment
seemed just not to be there
to get a college education.
So when Peter and I decided
to take this online for free,
we started, inevitably and
unintentionally, a movement
called Massive Open
Online Courses, or MOOC.
Many other companies followed--
EdX, Coursera, iversity,
and many others.
The thing that blew us
away was the sheer size
that you could reach
by going online.
Now, for all of you,
that's completely obvious.
From libraries to Google
is just completely obvious.
It's 100,000 times bigger
a market, 100 million times
as big a market.
But for education,
very few people
had really attained
global scale in education.
To make a long story
short, the numbers
that came out of this
class were staggering.
160,000 students signed
up in a short period.
23,000 finished.
This is a graduate level
artificial intelligence class.
There is not 160,000 people in
the world who care about AI.
We had an army of 1,950
volunteer translators
that translated the course into
44 languages in 195 countries.
This became the biggest
course ever taught
in the history of colleges.
In fact, I taught more
students in this class
than I can teach in
Stanford in 50 lifetimes.
The cost of doing this
is, the cost of building
the engineering, recording
all the videos and exercises,
and paying all the fees
for service providers,
was $0.60 per student.
Compare this to a $50,000 a
year Stanford tuition rate.
What was even more
staggering to me
was ranking the online students
with my Stanford students.
To remind you, Stanford students
go through an ardent process
of admission.
To get in, you have to be
wicked smart, the right age,
the right SAT scores, and
a wonderful statement, all
these things.
And even then, only a
few thousand students
get in every year, so they
ought to be the smartest
kids on the planet.
However, when we compared,
based on identical homework
assignments and exams, online
students with those Stanford
students the top 412
students were online
and the strongest of
200 Stanford students
ranked number 413.
As the course unfolded-- I'm
going to read this for you--
students started writing
me letters like this one.
I'm going to start at
the third paragraph.
"I'm completing the course from
remote areas of Afghanistan
and often don't have great
internet connectivity
or electricity or
internet connections that
wouldn't block YouTube.
I spent the last few days under
incoming mortar and rocket
attacks, then
dodging checkpoints
under questionable legal
status to exfiltrate a war
zone to a third world airfield
until things settled down.
I had about an hour of fairly
solid internet connectivity
to be able to get
the assignments done
and still managed a
respectable score.
This a typical
week for me here."
This wasn't a typical
Stanford student.
This was a brave soldier
fighting for a good cause
and trying to work on a
future past his military life.
This lady works
40+ hours a week.
She's a single mother of
two and her younger child
is only seven months old.
She has no time to
concentrate or to dedicate
and she's been hanging onto
a class by her fingernails,
waiting to learn and to feel
a sense of accomplishment.
"Just before homework
five was due,
I suffered another series of
great, chaotic difficulties."
It's a long story, but
basically, baby has been sick
and someone [INAUDIBLE]
has lost their home,
and their life became
really miserable.
"Why am I telling you
so much personal stuff?
Because on November
13, I gave up.
I told myself it was
ridiculous to think
I could justify
continuing this class,
thinking taking the time, given
all the other problems that
surrounded me.
And then on Monday
morning, I checked my email
and saw the note
you sent me Saturday
and I stared at it for awhile.
Then I sighed and told
myself I can't quit now.
I took the midterm exam
and finished the course."
Now, unbeknownst to her,
I had sent every student
that was late an email,
about 40,000, which
prompted about 40,000
personal responses like those,
which I didn't all read.
But still, there was a
moment here where I really
had to pause and
think, at Stanford,
I teach these wonderful kids
who are already extremely
privileged and I'm really
ignorant to the rest
of the world of people that
possibly need me much more,
like single mothers
raising children
wanting to reenter the
workforce, and she's not alone.
Here's a video that made me cry.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hello.
My name is Melody Bliss and I
was an advanced track student
at Stanford for the online
Introduction to Artificial
Intelligence class taught
by Professor Sebastian Thrun
and Peter Norvig.
I am also a disabled woman going
through dialysis three times
a week.
In addition, I am
still working full time
as a systems engineer
for a local company.
Because of this, I
went to this class
knowing that I would
have serious constraints
upon my time, and that gave
me some trepidation going
into the class, since there
would be many days where,
due to the dialysis
or other factors,
I just would not have the energy
to even watch a short video.
The enthusiasm that the
professors exhibit, however,
throughout the class
engages you, energizes you,
and infects you with the same
enthusiasm for the subject.
The short lectures
with quizzes helps
you realize that yes, you are
understanding the material,
and if you realize
that you are not,
it is easy to go back and review
the information until suddenly
you get that light bulb
over your head effect.
What I love most
about this class,
however, is how it
has given me new ideas
and how I could possibly
implement AI practices
in the work that I do today.
This has been one
of the best classes
that I have ever taken
and in my opinion
a wonderful use of the time
that I hold precious to me.
So I urge you, if you are
considering taking this class,
to do so.
It has changed my life and I
believe it can change yours,
too.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Thank you.
I'm still getting
moved when I see this
and I've seen it many times.
This was the beginning
when I realized
there's a mission
here, something
we do not well in society.
Education is
unevenly distributed.
We have the wrong
model of education
and we don't reach
everybody, so it
was time for me to wake up
and do something about it.
So we started Udacity, which
comes from the English word
"audacity," with
a single mission,
to truly democratize education.
We believe if you give a
man a fish, or a woman,
the person has
dinner for one night,
but if you teach him or
her how to catch fish,
they have food for the
rest of their lives.
We believe education is the
single most important thing
and should be a basic
human right codified
in the Constitution, the
right to free education.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
The very first thing
in trying to go global
was to think about what
is the delivery method.
Physical classrooms
don't scale very well,
so we decided to launch on
Android, on mobile platforms,
and on web browsers, to reach
the 3.7 billion people who
are already connected to
mobile or the web today.
We decided to focus a lot
on international students.
I'm putting this picture
up because Google has just
announced an
initiative to translate
six Google led and Google
developed classes into Arabic
and launch career centers
on the ground in Egypt
and issue 2,000 scholarships
to students in Egypt.
What makes me particularly
excited about that initiative
is that, especially
in the Arabic world, ,
there's a lack of
opportunity for young people,
and by creating
reputable, Google led,
state of the art instruction, we
can possibly give young people
a path to be productive
members in the Western world,
which I think will really change
the course of this geographic
region.
[APPLAUSE]
To quote my friend
Thomas Friedman, who
visited my company
recently-- Thomas Friedman
is a New York Times columnist.
He said, look, if there
is better education,
there would be less
reason to do things
like terrorism for some
people in these countries.
In terms of going global,
Google and Udacity
have a long history
working together.
We started about three
years ago and we let
students sign up for classes.
We have a freemium product,
which I'll explain in a sec.
And we signed up just south
of 900,000 students already.
Not all these students
finished, but we
have a portfolio
of classes that we
teach students anything between
HTML5, game development,
proper app development,
Android, and many other things,
and that's just the beginning.
With today's announcement,
or yesterday's announcement,
we extended it to
include certification
and we created the
nanodegree, which
I'll talk about in a second.
The next thing we decided to
do is we wanted to make it fun.
To me, sitting in a class with
500 other students watching
an aging professor
on stage telling me
the same story every year, in
and out again, is just not fun.
As many reasons to go
to college are fun,
that is not one of them.
So we wanted to
make learning fun.
We wanted to use the internet
to make it as fun as possible.
One of the things
that we realized
is in a physical
classroom, you're
forced to take everybody
at the same thought
at the same time,
just the way I'm
doing it with you right now.
In the online world,
it's completely OK
if people go at
a different pace.
That means you can make
education much more
interactive.
You can wait for a student
and you can make it
more like a video game.
We decided to put a very strong
project focus on education,
and I'm going to show
some of the projects
that people have built.
There's numerous,
a huge number of
interesting projects,
but I just picked these two
out in the graphics class,
and these are students who
had never programmed graphics
before.
So here's what's called
the Musical Turk.
Here you go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is a student who has
just taken his first graphics
class and decided to build
just a really fun app.
He's obviously a music lover.
So I can pick my
favorite composer
and you can
pre-guess what you're
about to hear by
looking at the picture.
This is Liszt, Franz Liszt.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Second project that
I dug out, again,
a student who has never
done graphics before.
It takes awhile to load.
And it's not perfect yet, but
this is a city driving project
which integrates head tracking.
So here I'm in a car, and
if everything goes well,
I can activate my own camera I
move my head left, right, left,
and then drive this car through
the city just using my head.
I'm not very good at this.
That's one of the
reasons why I actually
worked on self driving cars
because I'm a lousy driver.
But I found it just
amazing how students really
built these really
amazing applications.
Oops.
I'm dying.
Let's go back to
the presentation.
So we decided projects are
so much better than lectures.
You get to do something,
build something.
But to become a really
good project person
and build a portfolio, you need
feedback, so we needed people,
so we started hiring.
Hiring is hard.
We hired dozens of people
that would sit at Udacity
and grade all these projects.
And the company, when
we launched nanodegrees,
started growing almost
astronomically, roughly 5%
every week.
We couldn't hire that fast,
so our projects fell back
and it took us two weeks to
grade them just like college.
And then we got
students complaining,
I'm paying a monthly fee
for a two week delay.
You guys are getting
rich on my advantage.
And then we decided
to follow the model
that Travis at Uber and Lift
and Airbnb and many others
had developed where your
workforce becomes global.
We decided to democratize
not only the learning
part, but also the TA-ing
of classes, the code review.
We built a global
code reviewer network
and we're beginning to build
a global mentor network.
People all around
the world would now
be able to grab these
projects the same way an Uber
driver grabs your
request for a ride,
and then grade it really fast
and turn it around and give it
to the student.
The student would assess
the quality of the grading
and we would then compensate
the grader in correspondence
to the work and the
quality of the workmanship.
We launched this just
two or three months ago.
We now have about 350
or so worldwide graders
in all countries.
It's amazing.
They turn around projects
almost always within a day,
mostly within an hour.
So if you write your code
and you put it on GitHub
and you submit it to us,
you get detailed feedback
within an hour.
Anybody who's been in
college will say, oh my god,
this is possible?
These people make real money.
They make real money.
Actually, some of them
make more than me.
So the monthly income
of our best global code
reviewer is more than $11,000.
He's in South Africa,
does as a part time job
on the side over the
weekends, makes more with us
than with his main job.
And I just put this graph up
to compare the typical salary
that the typical
part time instructor
makes in a US institution, which
is actually very, very low.
And this big difference
in earning potential
is really the result
of true globalization.
If we tear down the
wall of colleges
and open it up to
the world, then we
have an amazing ecosystem we can
build about learners and people
to help them to learn.
Next, step five, we decided the
best opportunity that we have
that no college ever has is
to learn about our students.
When we put up a new
video, we do a new quiz,
a new exercise, typically, we
have about 1,000 or so students
at the same location
and we can get
almost instantaneous data about
people's learning abilities.
This is just one graph.
It graphs the student progress
over time as they engage.
Horizontal is time,
vertical is progress.
It's shocking.
Most college students
would be in a single line
because you're forced
to be in a single line.
Advanced people lose.
It's shocking to see
that some students stop
sleeping to finish the
course as fast as possible.
In fact, one student
wrote a blog post about us
and called the
phenomenon, the feeling
of taking a class with us,
"binge learning," which
I loved because that's
what it should be.
Step six.
This is a big step for me.
We wanted to make it
relevant, and that's
the reason why I'm
here today and why
we're working with Peter
and his wonderful team.
In areas, in ecosystems
as fast moving
as Android with more than a
billion active Android users
worldwide, many
more, it's important
that the education
is fresh, and that
is somewhat
irreconcilable with tenure
or with a primary
resource mission.
I challenged anybody
to find a good Android
class in any college in
this country at this point
or anywhere in the world.
There might be a few,
but by and large,
the speed at which academia is
able to adopt new technologies
is slow.
And very often, in places
like Facebook and Twitter
and others, when you
come out of college,
you have to be retrained
to be suitable to be
working in the 21st century.
That isn't to say that
colleges do a bad job.
They're just very different.
But we wanted to make it so
that it's really bleeding edge.
The things announced
at this conference
are already available as a
course in our new nanodegree.
So we teamed up with
companies, Google
being a wonderful
partner, and others,
to really bring top notch
education to everybody.
And then finally, we really
wanted to focus on jobs.
We believe that one of the core
value propositions of education
ought to be employment.
So we created this new
thing called nanodegree.
It never existed before.
It's not accredited.
There's no accreditation body.
Colleges don't do it.
It's a much smaller packaging
size than a college degree,
but it turns out
there's also no law
against inventing
new degrees, luckily,
so we could just do it.
And we launched them.
Typically, think of
them as six months long.
They can be faster.
In principle, you
could do it in a week.
They can be slower.
We care much more about
mastery than meeting
some artificial timelines,
but if you spend 10, 15,
20 hours a week on this and you
come with the right starting
knowledge, you should
be able to compete it
in four to six months,
maybe nine months.
We launched iOS, Front End
Development Programming,
Web Full Stack, Data
Analyst, and yesterday,
we announced Android
Developer, and we also
announced that we are
actively working on three more
Google led nanodegrees,
Entrepreneurship,
Cloud Development, and
Advanced Web Development.
And I'm particularly
proud of Entrepreneurship
because it's something that
people outside the tech field
can benefit from and
international people can
benefit from.
If you look at
youth unemployment
in Greece and Spain
exceeding way past 50%.
If we can teach them the tools
to be digital entrepreneurs,
we might be able
to get them dinner
for the rest of their lives.
We have numerous examples
of people finding jobs.
On the right side, you
see a Googler, Kelly,
who was a business
analyst and is now
a full stack
developer at Google,
and stayed at the same company.
Vicky in the center, she
became a data engineer
from a business analyst intern.
[INAUDIBLE] is a
golf professional
who, by his own words, says
he wasn't quite good enough
to make the cut and he became
a full stack developer.
We have working mothers who
want to reenter the workforce
and we have seafood managers
who become software engineers.
And there's a really strong
vision here, I believe.
When education was
invented, people
believed that one education
of a lifetime is enough.
Today, people have
many different careers,
and what Google
enabled people to do
is to go from here to here,
to take this job over here,
to be a high school teacher
and be hired into Google.
So here's some of our students.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi.
I'm Dennis Shen.
You can call me Den.
-My name is Maarten.
-Ubuntu Obatarhe, [INAUDIBLE].
-My name is Febria.
-Hello, everyone.
My name is Evgenii.
I'm from Sochi.
-I'm Dan Stormont.
-I'm Jessa.
I'm a software engineer
from the Philippines.
-My name is Genhady.
I am 27.
-I always wanted to do a
degree but I could not afford
moving out of my house either.
-The existing
system of education,
I think it's pretty much
ripe for disruption.
-I decided to change paths
and become a programmer.
-I've been learning online
for as long as I can remember.
-You kind of redefined what
I think is possible now.
-I was amazed how
much I could learn
in a very short period of time.
-Writing code is my passion.
I enjoy it a lot.
-The community is awesome.
You get to help each
other out [INAUDIBLE].
You get to ask questions.
You get to answer them, too.
-I find myself
having this ability
to think in different ways.
-It was a problem in my
village of my daily routine,
so I'm trying to solve
this problem with a piece
of [INAUDIBLE].
I solved my problem and
I didn't think about it.
-Every day, I
discover new things.
-It's been life changing.
-And by the end of the course,
I can build my own Android
application.
-I truly believe online learning
is the future of education.
-I got the position of
Java developer in startup.
-I manage the Google Developer
Group and the Women's Technical
Group in my university.
-And you can also keep
current on the things
that you need for
doing your job or just
to be a part of modern society.
-I adore programming and I have
developed some applications.
-I have a wonderful wife
and a beautiful one-year-old
daughter, and I feel
more motivated than ever
to give my family a better life.
-Every course has
application in my daily job
and gets me closer to my dream
of creating my own startup.
-Well, this was my story.
[INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
So how much does this cost?
Well, staying in tune with the
idea of truly democratizing
education and making it
accessible to everybody,
we made the decision that
all our content, everything
we built, is available
online for free,
so it's the equivalent
of a free textbook.
[APPLAUSE]
And I really want to
give kudos to Google.
Sundar yesterday in
his keynote mentioned
that there was a $4
million injection of money,
and that was really the
money it took to put together
all the content,
all the exercises
and projects for the Android
nanodegree and beyond.
However, as a
startup company, it's
not a good idea to give
everything away for free,
so we are truly a
freemium business.
The services we provide
where we pay our global code
reviewers money need, of course,
financing from the students.
We charge students
who want code feedback
and certification a $200
per month tuition fee.
Now, that's a lot of
money, but it's much less
than you pay for pretty much
any college in this country.
Now, this month, we
announced for the May cohort
and going forward that
if students finish,
they can ask for half
the tuition back.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
We did this because
we want the students
to go all the way to the end.
It will incentivize
every student
to say, look, you
make money back.
Udacity has a scholarship
program of 5,000 scholarships
for students in need, financed
in part by companies like AT&T,
and Google, as I mentioned
at the beginning,
just announced 2,000 full
scholarships for students
in Egypt.
And I hope that many Egyptian
students will sign up for this.
What many people don't know
is Egyptian computer science
students have a much higher
female ratio than this country,
and one of our goals is to
really help diversify and bring
everybody into computer science
and software engineering, not
just male, middle
aged men like myself.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
The last thing that I
found really amazing
is that Laszlo Bock
and his team at Google
have committed to do a
career summit in November,
and this is really
underlining the seriousness
of this education.
The Android
Development nanodegree
is not a beginner
level, easy to do thing.
It is serious education
with serious sweat
that we believe gets you to
the level of a nice, completely
competent Google employee
in software engineering.
And to underline this, 50 of
the top Android nanodegree
finishers will be invited, all
expenses paid, to Google campus
in November to meet lots
of Googlers, including
Google's recruiters, to chat
about careers and experience
Google firsthand.
I think Laszlo and
Peter and the teams
deserve a big applause
for doing this, because--
[APPLAUSE]
It really sets the stage
for possibly a new way
of finding those 412 students
that beat the single strongest
Stanford student.
Before I open up for
Q&A, I want to also
share with you one video
that completely surprised me
by my own company and that
I've watched maybe 500 times.
It is one of our professors,
in this case, a great colleague
from Brown University
and from Georgia Tech,
getting creative in
this meeting that you
wouldn't believe is possible.
So let me go here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: This is
part of a Udacity class.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is professor--
-(SINGING) You've got some data.
You need to find a
rule that can predict.
You want a theta that works
for any instance that you pick.
It's Bellman's curse.
The classifer needs to--
[END PLAYBACK]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
You can actually go
online and see it.
This course was actually
instructed by two people.
And the second person
said he couldn't sing,
so we got a role for him.
Let's see.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Saves your day, but
what a chilling plot
this is to find the
right hypothesis.
You let your guard
down one small bit.
Oh no, it seems you've underfit.
Like scary films in cinema,
you're trapped in local minima.
[END PLAYBACK]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: All right.
Questions?
There's microphones here.
Come forward, please.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm not
going to make a question.
I just want to say
thank you because girls
like me can learn
more about code
and this is very emotive for
me because seven months ago, I
didn't know anything
about coding,
and now I've got my own startup
up with 12,000 users in it.
And I also belong
to a community that
is looking for seven
to 11-year-old girls
to learn more about code, so
I just want to say thank you.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Please come visit us.
Honestly, these are
the moments that
make me do what I want to do.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually more
of a database developer, which
I actually started
learning on my own.
The company that my
husband was working for
were willing to give me a
chance to do that, which
I know that's an
incredible circumstance
to end up in because most people
don't have something like that.
But I was wondering
if-- I've actually
had quite a few women
in my area ask me,
how do you get into
database development?
What can I do about it?
Do you guys have
anything in the works
that you might be
looking to do that,
or can I put a bug
in your ear for that?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We have a
class that we built with MongoDB
and we have several
classes with Cloudera where
we did data analysis,
some were with Salesforce,
but no nanodegree yet.
We'd love to have a nanodegree
The model that's been
working is that companies,
mostly in Silicon Valley,
come to us, knock on our door,
and say, look, this is an area
we think is really important.
And then we answer those queries
and say, let's get together
and see what it would take.
How big is the market size?
Who will be the typical student?
And then we end up after a few
meetings defining a curriculum
that we believe
is bleeding edge.
We definitely will
put a lot of oil
into the fire of building
more content and more
nanodegrees inside coding
and outside coding, to we're
extremely open to suggestions.
My email is thrun@udacity.com
or thrun@stanford.edu.
Please send me an email, OK?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So it's a
really great product,
and I'm curious you have
any aspirations-- most
of the courses right now are
technology related-- for just
a broader curriculum that
isn't necessarily based
on technology.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yes.
The reason why we
focused on technology
is I think it's good
to be good in something
that's confined first and
really work with out the kinks.
Also, technology is one of the
most employable areas today.
With the entrepreneurship
nanodegree
that we are building
right now, we're
branching out a little bit.
It's still technology
based in the sense
that we believe that
every entrepreneur has
to know a lot about
analytics and website domain
and mobile and so on, but it's
much more basic in some sense.
As the company
hopefully grows, we
will look into adjacent areas.
The thing we're probably
never going to do
is philosophy or art
history, or if we do it,
I want to do it
completely differently.
I want to do it in a way
that the people coming out
of these humanities
classes are absolutely
employable by Facebook and by
Google and by tech companies
because I think there's a huge
shortage of great humanity
thinking in the tech field.
But the way it's being
taught today, in my opinion,
is very separate.
It's very disjoint from what
the workforce needs are,
and Udacity's promise
really is jobs.
We want people to
find employment
as a proxy for
contributing to society.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SEBASTIAN THRUN:
Yes, over there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you've been a pioneer
in this technology
that we've seen sort of explode
over the last couple of years.
I've known people
who've taken courses
on EdX and Coursera
and Udacity and it's
changed all of their
lives considerably.
What do you see as
the future of what
are now these fragmented
online education
courses like Khan Academy?
There are some
that appear to have
very different educational
areas, but in the future,
do you see education
becoming more unified
or separate across these
companies, or what direction?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We're
certainly living right now
in an area of great
experimentation in education,
and it's wonderful, honestly.
It's been long overdue.
And it's great to see so
many companies engaging
in the same space and
trying to innovate
and finding the right formula.
It's completely obvious to
me that 50 years from now,
education will be what Larry
Page calls a toothbrush
technology, we use twice
a day for five minutes.
It's completely obvious to
me that the Prussian picture
of childhood play,
go educate yourself,
work, and retire is
obsolete, that we
have to intermix these things
and be lifelong learners.
And that means education
has to be available
wherever you go-- on your phone,
on your watch, on your devices,
and blend into a
physical, busy life.
And that's basically
what we do and what
other companies are doing.
It's also completely
obvious to me
it's going to be open,
democratic to everybody.
We can't lock it up anymore.
I think it's almost
a crime that we
have this amazing,
great education
in this country, the best
education in the world,
and no one gets in.
Almost nobody gets in.
And it thrives from
exclusivity in that
to keep your ratings up,
you have to be exclusive.
You can't be inclusive.
So I think education
50 years from now
will be with us
all the time and it
will be an absolutely
great thing to do,
instead of watching
a movie, to go
learn a skill that you can
leverage to work and make
yourself smarter.
The path there, who knows
what's going to happen?
I mean, obviously, I'm putting
my own time into my own company
and we're trying to do our
very best job to reinvent
everything, from the
basic credentialing
system to the quality of the
videos to the experience,
but more important than
my company winning is
that somebody wins and really
breaks into this big wall
of existing education systems.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So there are
claims that the completion
rates of these online
courses are really low.
Is that correct?
And if it's correct, have
you seen any difference
with such nanodegrees?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yes.
The Massive Open Online
Courses have often
been critiqued for
completion rates
typically in the
order of 2% to 5%,
and our numbers are the same.
Obviously, when we
have paying students,
we drive up completion
because if you pay money,
you're more committed.
But also, we found that by
offering intense services--
mentoring services, tutoring
services, and feedback--
we drive up completion rate.
I don't have a good
number right now.
I ran it for one
of my own courses,
which is a bit of
an exaggeration,
so it's not typical
for a company,
but I'm teaching a course how
to program a self driving car.
It's a robotics
class and it's being
taught as an open MOOC where
you get a 2.3% finishing rate.
As Udacity, in this case,
also a Georgia Tech class
that is embedded
in the degree, we
get a completion
rate north of 90%.
I think our typical completion
rates are more like 50% or so.
It's a factor of many things.
It's a factor of
the fact that we
have no admissions
for our nanodegrees
so people can just
come, so many people
are not well fit for
the nanodegrees who
are working on this.
The Android nanodegree now has
a little admissions hurdle.
You have to do a self test.
Also, overall, I think that 50%
is certainly better than 3%,
and one of the things
my company cares
a lot about, every
single person,
is bringing this up to 100%.
We really care about
educating not just
the top of students who could
probably learn from books,
but also the bottom of students.
So come visit Udacity.
Perhaps you'll sign up for
one of the nanodegrees,
and then give us feedback
how we can make it better.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Rasha.
I now take the front end
nanodegree on Udacity.
I actually won the sponsorship
money through Udacity contest
as well, which was awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
I was wearing the cape in the
photo that I participated in.
That's what made me win.
Anyway, I've been following up
with Udacity and it's amazing.
I love how easy it is to
actually build something
useful through the course.
So you actually are very
proud by the end of the course
because you built something.
I was wondering, because you
mentioned the partnership
with Egypt, why that
country, and is there
any plans for
localizing content,
for example, making it
available in Arabic?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
So the Egypt pilot involves
complete translations
into Arabic so that students
not even proficient in English
could complete the
basic experience
and take these courses.
Google has subtitled
their classes
for 10 different
languages, and we
are between 1 and 10
languages for other courses.
Obviously, localization is a
big part of going international.
India we have a lot of traction,
where many students already
speak native
English, and we have
plans to open a China
office and go into China
later this summer to
reach Chinese students.
I am specifically
enthusiastic about Egypt.
Google has a really
great relationship
with the Egyptian government
and the Egyptian government
is very eager to empower its own
people, so some of these things
came together.
But for us, it's a
platform to reach
much more than just Egypt.
It's a platform to reach
the entire peninsula
and really reach
a lot of people--
everybody, but hopefully a
lot of people who otherwise
would have no chance to
be a productive member
in the society.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for what you're doing.
I'm a professor at Cal
Poly in San Luis Obispo.
I teach computer science
and Android development,
and so I'm the guy, in a
way, that you're replacing,
and that's OK.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We do have
open requisitions right now
and we're not far from you.
We pay well.
AUDIENCE: You pay
well, probably better.
I'm excited about
what is happening.
I mean, I can relate
to what you're saying.
It is very difficult
for a professor
to keep up with technology.
I'm not a full time
Android developer.
I teach a lot of courses.
I get to teach
Android maybe once
a year, one quarter, one course,
and so it is a challenge.
How do you see what
you're doing integrating,
or do you see it
integrating at all?
Can we leverage and work
together in different ways?
Do you mind if I use
some of your content
in some of my courses to scale
my courses, things like that?
SEBASTIAN THRUN:
All our content you
can use for free as
much as you want,
and if you charge tuition
based on our content,
please keep it, absolutely.
Actually, I'm really impressed
that there was an Android
course in San Luis Obispo.
I've seen very
few in the nation,
so big kudos for
teaching Android.
This is actually great.
[APPLAUSE]
That's actually remarkable
because most professors teach
what they did in
their PhD thesis
for the rest of
their career, myself
included when I was at Stanford.
Things that come along
as fast as Android
typically are completely
dismissed by academia,
and as a result,
students coming out
don't have the skills
that they would
need, for example, to
be productive on day one
at Google.
The truth is our
content is being
used by many, many universities
and many high schools
and many colleges.
In fact, Sal Khan started
an elementary school,
and my son is on it, and that
school uses one Udacity class.
So the kids, the
10-year-olds, nine-year-olds,
are learning genomics on
Udacity, which blows my mind.
Our goal really is to reach
as many people as possible
and we are very
interested in feedback.
So for example, if you use
materials in the classroom
and find services that we
offer or content useful,
please come back to us.
Tell us how you used it.
Come visit us.
Our goal really is to-- looks
like it just lost sound.
Maybe one last question in
the interest of time right
over here.
AUDIENCE: That's really funny
timing because my question was
going to be how professors
and university college
administrators are
reacting to this.
So maybe you
answered my question,
but from your perspective, your
colleagues or ex-colleagues,
how are people reacting to this?
Are they seeing
that there's a need
to change traditional
university education,
or at least change the
content or try and keep up
with content?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: When you go
out and think of something well
established like academia and
go to people and say, look,
we can do for $0.60 what you
guys charge $50,000 for, you
don't just end up with friends.
So if you do a Google search on
my name about a year and a half
ago when we worked
with a local university
to make San Francisco
State's college education 10%
as expensive as
it is today, you'd
find a few labor unions taking
a little bit of an issue
with me, as was manifold.
One specific day, I bought
the New York Sunday Times
and I wouldn't even have to
flip over the first page.
Above the fold,
they called my work
a flop and the
Financial Times said
we're going out of business.
I think the way it's coming out
is actually really interesting.
With all the rhetoric of
replacing college, which
of course hasn't happened, the
main quote, unquote "customer"
that we have is actually very
different in demographics.
The main customers we have
are young professionals
and middle aged professionals
and some high aged
professionals typically
past college age,
and the reason why
that's the case
is there's an enormous
thirst for learning.
A generation ago, employment
lasted for a lifetime.
Today, employment lasts
4.6 years on average,
going to the Bureau
of Labor Statistics,
and tomorrow, it might
just last for a year.
Ad hoc employment
through Airbnb and Uber
doesn't necessarily
last that long.
So I think especially
young people today
are completely
conscientious that they
have to stay on top of things
to be able to engage themselves.
It's not OK anymore to
just get one college degree
and stay there.
So the intersection between
our current customers
and college students at this
point is virtually zero,
and that has really calmed down
the discussion quite a bit.
So we are reaching people
all around the world
that existing colleges
don't even want to reach.
Existing colleges
really specialize
on the age of 17 to 24
and are doing a good job.
There's nothing bad
about going to college,
nothing bad about going
to Stanford or San
Luis Obispo Polytech,
but we are ending up
having this huge
number of people that
currently are
completely excluded
from the educational system.
In the interest of
time, thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
One last shout out to
Peter Lubbers over here--
stand up again-- who is
doing the work at Google,
and his team.
[APPLAUSE]